my name is dr. Anita Ramirez and I'm a
professor of engineering here and I'm a
scientist and the reason why I created
science Saturday's is that when I was
growing up I didn't really see too many
scientists that seemed to look like me
or seem to have my kind of interests and
so in my time here at Yale I've stumbled
on a few people who are doing such
wonderful science but also have a
diversity of backgrounds and so today we
have a dr. Peter salivate who will be
talking to us a little bit he'll be
talking to us about emotional
intelligence well we're in good hands
because he's kind of the creator of the
concept and Peter's a little too modest
so I'm gonna brag a little bit about him
he's the Dean of Yale College which is
one of the highest position that you one
of the highest positions that you can
have it this 300 over 300 year old
institution it's not bad for a kid from
New Jersey he came here from he came
here as a junior professor and slowly
worked his way up to be distinguished
he's now got a chaired position he was
also Dean of the Graduate School and now
he's Dean of the college itself now from
that description or which is actually
he's done quite a bit which you know
would take up an entire lecture time we
can see that Peter has a lot of energy
and but we'll also see that he's got a
lot of enthusiasm and the thing that I
admire about him is that he has a way to
really convey science in a palatable way
so hopefully we'll get to see some of
him his magic today so let's warmly
warmly welcome Peter to the podium
thank you
thank you very much I appreciate you all
coming on a Saturday morning and for
what for some of you is a holiday
weekend and it's really nice that so
many people came today and I want to
thank professor Ramirez for putting this
program together if you saw the poster
you'll see that there are many Saturday
mornings during the spring well there'll
be some really interesting people
presenting from all kinds of different
science and engineering fields
let me introduce mark Brackett who is
sitting over here drinking his coffee
and he's going to share the hour with me
and in the following way I'm going to
tell you a little bit about emotional
intelligence and then he's going to do
an exercise with you where you can learn
to develop your own emotional
intelligence through that exercise what
I'm not going to do even though there is
a whole science here and we do studies
out in the real world that we do
experiments in my lab on human emotions
and how they work and how they affect
thinking and how they affect behavior
I'm not gonna really walk you through
very much of that science I'm really
going to tell you more about what
emotional intelligence is and how we
measure it and let you try to test
yourself a little bit and then and then
as I said mark will do a little exercise
with you if we if you want to learn more
about this I can tell you at the end
about websites and and other things that
we've written that might provide more
information and a little bit more of the
science behind all of this so I'm going
to ask the question emotional
intelligence is there anything to it but
you know that already know the answer
I'm gonna give because if the answer was
no I'd be finished with my talk right
now
but we're gonna argue that the answer is
yes there is something to it and it's
something that you might want to develop
in your own lives so let me start by
asking you to take a look at this
photograph and I show you this for if
not to sort of show off hey look at me
I'm meeting President Clinton but to
contrast the people in this photo with
respect to their emotion related skills
look notice how the people in this slide
look how does this person look Reserve's
but what else what else do you see in
her face calm what else
contend worried a little bit she looks a
little bit like she's just seen a ghost
actually to me but right and look at
this person here he's working his wife
president's working his way around the
room shaking hands and she's just
shaking hands with him she's just
shaking hands with him no I'm shaking
hands with him here's my wife well how
does she look she went a little
something like Paro look at my husband
he's shaking hands with pro-clinton
dinner and now this person here on the
right this person here on the right in
the in the striped sweater what does she
look like yeah it's a fake smile it is a
fake smile you can tell that because
she's got a little bit of the mouth
going but not the eyes and the reason
why it's a fake smile is why now I think
she's just nervous you know she's
getting wet you know you get two
sentences to say to the president and
she's thinking of her two sentences
right now and she is trying to get ready
to say now look at me and and President
Clinton notice the difference in our
faces yes he has more gray hair than me
and he's taller that goes without saying
but notice the difference I'm looking
happy but but anxious I'm worried that
I'm going to make a bad impression on
him we we had actually met out in front
of the building about 10 minutes earlier
so what he's saying to me right now is
didn't I just meet you out in front of
the building aren't you the Dean and I'm
sitting there thinking don't say
anything stupid don't say anything
so I look very anxious happy but anxious
and you can see it because I'm all kind
of I'm sort of hunched up and you can
see a little bit things that it's not
obvious you know I'm good I can cover up
the anxiety a bit but he
the most comfortable person in this room
is clearly Bill Clinton and Bill Clinton
was famous for being a very emotionally
engaging person he was the person who
would say I feel your pain right he
understands your emotions people who
meet him always would talk about how
Bill Clinton made you feel comfortable
he made you feel like you were the only
person in the room that he was talking
only to you and that's certainly what
he's doing here he's making me feel very
important like like he's happy to meet
me as opposed to I'm happy to meet him
and and he's trying to put me at my ease
these are very good skills to have he's
looking to make me feel comfortable
you'll also notice he's trying to make
sure my wife doesn't feel left out and
so look where his left hand is it's
around her shoulders he's bringing her
into the conversation and for the
parents in the room you may think that
that also talks about that also reminds
us of some of the problems that Bill
Clinton actually had regulating his
emotions problems we don't need to go
into this morning now I put this slide
up to remind us that people differ
people differ in the skills with which
they deal with their emotions the
emotions of other people their ability
to manage emotions if I were better at
managing my own emotions I would look
nothing but overjoyed as opposed to
happy but nervous and and also their
ability to regulate the emotions of
other people Bill Clinton is making me
feel trying to make me feel more
comfortable now why do we think it's
important to look at emotions in this
way to look at these individual
differences in the way in which people
deal with their emotions and the
emotions of other people well the reason
we think it's important to look at these
things is because we believe that our
emotions are smart that we have evolved
an emotional system because it helps us
survive in the world now Darwin never
used the word of
intelligence but we think if Darwin were
alive today he might Darwin might say
aren't our emotions are an intelligent
system and they're an intelligent system
for two primary reasons first are it's
our emotions that help us survive in the
world by energizing behavior that we
need to do in the immediate situation to
help us survive or help our species
survive so for example if I'm being
chased by a predator that wants to eat
me and I'm feeling afraid that fear
makes me run faster and I escape the
predator if an enemy or another member
of my species is blocking a goal my goal
is to eat that food over there and
another I'm a dog and another dog is
trying to eat that food or block me from
eating that food what do I do
well I look angry and I snarl and if I
get angry enough I have to it helps me
chase away the other dog or fight the
other dog so what are what our emotions
do in part is energize our behavior so
that we get up and do what we need to do
okay you all probably know if you play
sports a certain amount of emotion helps
you play better sports too much maybe in
the end and you get worse right but but
you can run faster if you're feeling
something than if you're feeling nothing
the other reason why Darwin might have
said our emotions are smart is because
our emotions are accompanied by
something on our face that communicates
something to our species mates or maybe
even to another species it communicates
that there is something going on in this
environment that needs to change what
could that be well Darwin laid out a few
of these in his book called the
expression of emotions in man and
animals he said what do what do most
animals do when they're angry they bare
their teeth and growl and what is that
communicating that's communicating
you're annoying me
you're blocking my goal you're getting
in my way and you see these people I
right you see them they're gonna end up
sunk into your flesh if you don't knock
it off okay and then the other animal
backs away typically and everybody lives
survives to see another day which that's
that's Darwin's bottom line right when I
smile when an animal smiles or does
something that looks like we say looks
like smiling the animal is communicating
I have teeth but I'm not going to use
them today on you right it's safe to
approach me maybe the easiest one to see
is fear let's imagine a bunch of sheep
you don't see sheep in new haven very
often but try to imagine a bunch of
sheep and they're they're grazing in a
flock and an enemy of sheep arrives on
the horizon sitting on a a bluff on a
hill looking down at the Sheep is a
coyote and the coyote is looking at the
Sheep looking as chops getting ready to
thinking about which of these sheep is
going to become its lunch right which
sheep is he going to turn into a lamb
chop well imagine how imagine if every
sheep in the flock had to look up see
that coyote recognize it as a predator
and make a plan and then act on that
plan and run away well some of those
sheep who looked the ones who look up
last they're going to new they're going
to be behind the flock they're going to
be the last sheep out of the pad of the
meadow and they're probably going to
turn into the lunch of that coyote in
fact that's not what happens what
happens is the sheep are looking around
like sheep kind of randomly right so she
was just they just sort of look around
one of them happens to see the coyote
the coyote triggers a what we would say
is a fear response in that cheap and the
Sheep gets a look on its face okay I I
grew up in cities and so I've never
really seen this look in a sheep maybe
someone here has but I imagine what that
chief does is something like this right
that's the sheep in the headlights look
that's and that signals that that she
that signals to all the other sheep that
there's something wrong in fact the
sheep who has that look he might make
some noise bleat or something to call
attention to that face all the other
sheep look at that face see that face
and say I don't know why he looks that
way
but I'm getting out of here and they do
they start to run it triggers a kind of
response where they they run away well
it's not just sheep who do this it's
humans who do this so if you go to a
preschool and look at little kids say
three-year-olds two-year-olds a plane
and imagine you give the two or
three-year-old a new toy to play with
I'll tell you that's a little scary for
it to a three-year-old okay maybe it's a
big puppet or or something like the
Energizer Bunny that's making a lot of
noise and what happens well the two or
three-year-old typically will look at
the toy and then look around for an
adult that it knows often its mom but it
doesn't have to be it can be dad it
could be but usually some adult that it
knows who has played a caretaking role
in that baby's life and I didn't that
toddler's life looks around and looks
right at his or her face and what that
two and three year old is looking for is
something reassuring in the face so if
mom or dad smiles you know it makes a
big smile
the towards Riera will then move toward
the toy but if mom looks really worried
if mom looks like the sheep who sees the
coyote what will that what will the two
or three-year-old ooh typically back
away from the toy won't play with that
toy you could see this in infant you can
see this in in a baby less than a year
old okay and what they're doing is
exactly what the sheep are doing they're
using the emotional expressions of
someone else to try to decide if the
situation is safe or not we call this
social referencing and it's the kind of
thing that Darwin described it's the
kind of thing that helps a species or an
individual survive now there are other
reasons why we know that emotions are
smart
this is a really unfortunate person in
this slide if this happens to you
III was going to introduce this line say
here are a couple of professors at Yale
but I realized that you might believe me
let me tell you what what happened to
this guy this was a guy named Phineas
Gage okay and Phineas Gage lived in
Vermont where he was a railroad worker
in the nineteenth century in the middle
of the nineteenth century
and Phineas Gage had a really
interesting job his job was to look at
where the railroad track needed to be
built and drill a hole if there was
rocks in the way bit bolt you know
boulders or cliffs or mountains in the
way to drill a hole on the rock fill the
hole with gunpowder tamp it down with an
iron rod and then put a fuse in it move
far away light the fuse blow up the rock
okay that's how they put railroads
through well one day Phineas Gage had a
horrible thing happened to him in fact
the day was September 13th 1848 it was
at 4:30 in the afternoon he was sort of
at the end of his workday
and what happened at Phineas gates well
he found there was a huge boulder in the
way of the railroad track and so he
drilled a hole in it and he filled the
hall with gunpowder and he took out his
tamping iron the big rod that he used to
smash down the Gunpowder and he started
to tamp it down and the iron rod rubbed
against the rock side of the rock in the
hall and created spark and the spark lit
the Gunpowder so that the rod and it
blew up I mean it blew up in a big way
because there was a lot of gunpowder in
that hole and the ride shot out of the
hole in the rock and he was of course at
the time looking in the hall right
because he's tamping this down it shoots
out and it it it it fires itself right
through his skull I don't know this is
sort of disgusting for Saturday morning
but kids it's up right through his skull
from the
basically below his cheek right and
comes out the top so that when the
doctors find him as I know it's
disgusting when the doctors find him
he's laying on the ground with a rod
coming up through his skull and out the
top of his head and what you see is it
has destroyed a piece of his brain okay
now the doctors the amazing thing about
this story especially when you think of
it think it's it's 1848 the amazing
thing about this story is that the
doctors pull the rod out I think with no
anesthesia but that's not so bad the
brain doesn't have much in the way of
pain receptors so it doesn't really hurt
him that much when they pull the rod out
when the rod went in that hurt taking it
out that was nothing and I'd say pull
the rod out he recovers and I could show
you slides of a clay model of his head
you could see he recovers he's got an
intact head and the scar tissue has
grown over the hole in the top and he
recovers and he's walking and talking
he lives another 25 years Phineas Gage
does he doesn't do too much more
railroad work fact he takes early
retirement but you know the two amazing
things are a that he's alive and be that
he isn't walking around the rest of his
life with a big rock coming out of his
head so but he's not the same person
he's not the same person the rod has
destroyed a lot of the parts of the
brain having to do with his emotions and
his ability to control his emotions and
so most of the time he's pretty flat
doesn't really have many emotions at all
and some of the time he gets riled up
for no reason
but he's got his emotional system is
kind of haywire now what's interesting
is he also can't make decisions he has
no preferences anymore he doesn't know
what he likes and what he doesn't like
you would say to Phineas Gage would you
like chocolate vanilla or strawberry I
don't care if there was television
at the time which of course there wasn't
if you said to him what would you like
to watch on TV he wouldn't know what he
wanted to watch he could answer the
question I don't care whatever you want
I don't know vanilla chocolate doesn't
matter to me and the reason why is he's
the part of his brain that was still
intact that was not damaged were the
parts that have to do with
decision-making in problem-solving but
they didn't have access they didn't have
connections anymore to the part that had
to do with emotions and because he
didn't have the parts that had to do
with emotion anymore the part that had
to do with decision-making couldn't draw
on his emotions to help him make
decisions we need our emotions in order
to think to problem-solve to make
decisions to decide what we like and
don't like okay so our emotions are
smart not just because they help us
survive in the way that Charles Darwin
would have said but they're also smart
in the sense that they inform our
decision-making they help us make
decisions okay they help us solve
problems okay so with these ideas in
mind a few years ago we proposed maybe
there's an intelligence of emotions
maybe there's a way in which some people
are particularly good at monitoring
their own and other field people's
feelings that is observing them
discriminating among them that is
telling them apart and using this
information to guide their thinking and
their behavior and we argue that this is
an emotional intelligence and we can
break that down if you want we could say
an emotional intelligence has four basic
kinds of skills that is identifying or
perceiving your emotions and other
people's emotions right using those
emotions to help you think understanding
emotions that is particularly being able
to talk about them use language to
describe them and managing your emotions
calming yourself down when you're upset
psyching yourself up when you need to be
psyched up
calming somebody else down when they're
upset that would be
emotions and that's and so we try to
develop a test to see if we could I
identify people who are particularly
good at these sorts of things or people
who weren't so good and could learn to
be better and so we developed the test
called the Mesquite which stands for
mayor salivate caruso emotional
intelligence test those are the other
two guys who helped with jak mayor is a
professor at the University of New
Hampshire and David Caruso is a
psychologist who works with people in
business in Fairfield County Connecticut
and we we develop little tasks that we
use that we hoped would help us figure
out who is good at these skills and who
could learn to be better at these skills
and so we had tasks like the following
I'm going to ask you to see if you can
guess the answers here this one's kind
of easy
we would ask things like what emotions
do you see in this person's face what
emotions do you see in this person's
face that's good Deas he fared some
people see fear very good he says he
sees just a little fear there maybe
she's worried about getting her picture
taken and is kind of uncomfortably
smiling for the camera doesn't want an
embarrassing picture and you're right
there's actually this is actually a kind
of classic fake smile the mouth is
smiling but the eyes aren't smiling very
much at all the eyes and a real smile
your mouth is curled up but your eyes
crinkle in the corners too and her eyes
aren't quickly very much because she's a
little afraid so you might say this is a
3 or 4 unhappiness and maybe a 2 on fear
something like that
ok of course we asked many more
questions with many more faces we might
show you something that an artist
creates and we would say how much is
each of the following feelings expressed
by the artist in this picture so the
artist has painted this picture come
back the artist has painted this
and we would ask how much happiness is
the artist trying to convey how much
sadness fear anger anybody have any
ideas about this way yes looks more
sadness than happiness why is that for
you looks dark
it's a sunset the day is fading away a
day is turning in tonight yeah great
that's good so that to him that that
conveys a bit of sadness but it's the
end of the day not the beginning of the
day it's interesting about half the
people I show this picture to say it's
the dawn of a new day and about half the
people say the Sun is setting and I
think it depends on whether you live on
the east coast or the west coast we can
also ask you questions that try to get
you to use the language of your other
senses seeing hearing tasting smelling
touching to describe emotions I find
these very card but here's a here's a
question imagine feeling totally
surprised because you got a birthday
present that was unexpected how much is
the feeling of surprise like like cold
or warm like blueness the colour like
sweet like sour like salty you get get
the idea I find these very difficult to
do a lot of people find them difficult
to do kind of a weird question okay we
might ask some questions about how your
emotions connect to your thinking so
imagine you're Sherlock Holmes and
you're trying you're a detective and
you're trying to solve a crime what
emotion might help you solve the crime
well it turns out we've done studies in
my lab where we put people into
different emotions and we look at in
which emotional states are they better
at solving these would be like a
deductive reasoning problem solving
certain kinds of reasoning problems like
a detective solving a crime turns out a
little bit of negative emotion helps you
it focuses you
it makes you very attentive to detail
concerned about missing out missing
something okay Darwin might have argued
that this makes sense anyway do people
have to people know this people know
this at all
other questions this one might be a
little hard for younger people here but
some of you know the word contempt right
like being in contempt of court in a
courtroom
what is contempt we'll just ask you a
vocabulary question what is content well
it might be a mixture of what how many
people think it's surprise and anger
anger and fear anger anxiety and fear or
disgust and anger a lot of people think
disgust and anger hatred and guilt okay
turns out that you get points on these
tests for the best answer you get most
points but you also get points for
answers that people general people or
experts depending on how we score it
think our plausible answers to probably
the best answer is D disgust we can all
let me give you a couple of different we
can also ask questions about managing
your emotions so this is a little hard
to see but we ask you questions about
the effectiveness how useful different
ways of managing their feelings might be
so this is about a person named Debbie
she's just come back from vacation she's
feeling peaceful and content basically
happy how well would each of the
following actions keep her feeling happy
and content right the ideas she wants to
stay happy what does she do now well she
starts to make a list of things at home
that she needs to do how many people
think that would be a good strategy not
a very good strategy she began thinking
about where and when to go on her next
vacation that's pretty good strategy
been on a great vacation so I thinking
about the next one she decided it was
best to ignore the feeling would that
maintain it probably not she called a
friend to tell her about the vacation
that's a good answer too so we all agree
that number two and number four are
probably better answers than number one
or number three for staying happy I'll
give you one more of these and then
we'll move on so Ken and Andy are very
good friends from 10 years recently
let's say Andy was put in charge of a
project but Karen was appointed to be
the helper on the project okay so he
feels dissed and he begins to dislike
Andy but he feels bad about not like
Andy's his old friend Andy's been put in
charge of him
you don't like it he starts to hey Tandy
but he feels bad about hating Andy so
what might he do well he might whoops
come back come back he might try to
understand Andy's new role and try to
adjust anybody think that's a good good
idea not a bad idea
he's more likely to do that one than the
other and that's right Ken another
possibility is he would approach Andy
confront him that is getting angry at
him and tell him you know you're not
going to boss me around anymore how many
people think that would be good at yeah
I thought you might think that would be
a good idea anyway some of these are
better than others and I'll let you try
to figure out which ones those might be
well it's interesting when we look at
people we've now given this test we gave
it to 5,000 people mark how many people
now would you say I've taken that test
10,000 good 10,000 people have taken
this test and we all we also have a
version for kids of different ages this
one's for kids who are a little older
than some of you and for adults but we
also have one for middle school students
too and we find that that people who
score better on these kinds of questions
are people who remember their their
childhood their early childhood and say
I had a good relationship with my
parents our people who are more likely
to put photographs in their room of
their family members our people who like
to work with children
people who are not likely less likely to
use drugs and our people who are less
likely to get into fights and one day
when we talk to their teachers their
teachers tell us they don't know how the
kids in the class have scored but
they'll say see this kid right here she
never never gets in a fight with another
kid and then will look up the score and
we'll see oh she did well on the test
what else do they do well these are
adults working at a company in
Connecticut an insurance company in
Connecticut and we measured their
emotional intelligence using our test
and then we watched them for a while and
we asked the other people in their
workplace and their bosses to describe
these people and the ones who scored
high on our tests were described by
their boss and their other and the other
workers as more sensitive as more
sociable that is more friendly as
someone you like better as someone who
makes it fun to work at this company as
someone who deals with stress well
someone who's generally in a good mood
and someone who they think would be a
good leader now what would you say if we
really wanted to know whether our test
predicts something important at work
something that that would reflect that
you're a really good worker and you've
done a good job in this company what
what do you what kind of data should we
collect what would we really want to
know
salary right we'd really want to know
who gets a big raise at the end of the
year and who does it and so we in fact
did that and we found that we could
predict based on the test which people
got big raises at the end of the year
and which people that small raises at
the end of the year okay it wasn't
perfect and there are other factors that
went into whether someone got a bigger
small wave but we could about 25% of the
variable
we could account for with their
emotional intelligence that's pretty
good it's pretty good I could have I
could have taken bets with people about
who's gonna get the biggest raise at the
end of the year and won some of those
bets I actually think that's a little
scary maybe you do too anyway they got
bigger raises higher salaries and they
were promoted faster in this company
okay one last set of examples and then
I'm gonna things over to mark and he's
going to talk to you about how you can
work on your own emotional intelligence
we did a study when we went into a
school basically these were I think
eighth and ninth graders if I remember
and we measured emotional intelligence
in the school that's what a IQ is that's
their up their score and we simply asked
these students to write a story about a
time when somebody was pressuring them
to do something they didn't want to do
and to talk about all the emotions they
were feeling in that situation and all
the ways in which that situation was
difficult for them and what did they do
okay and what I want you to notice is
the way the emotions and the maturity
with which he stood it's talked about
the situation and note their di their
emotional intelligence score at the same
time so here's somebody who gets a
hundred and a hundred is average okay
100 is average and he says they wanted
me to beat the hell out of someone
violence makes me uncomfortable but they
won I fought but he says I try not to
hurt him I try not to harm him now
what's interesting about this guy he's
average and he says you know they tried
to make me do something I didn't want to
do and I did it anyway and he also
doesn't talk too much about emotion and
his feelings and the pressure he was
under but he does say one nice thing
which is that he actually didn't try to
hurt the person okay let's look at
another person notice this person has an
even higher score some of my friends
did mooning cars we all we all know what
this is right I don't have to explain it
please don't make me explain this I
would write dr. Brackett says you can
explain it just don't demonstrate it I
was in Japan last week talking about
emotional intelligence and I used this
example in Japan and I looked at the
audience most of whom did not speak
English they were translating and I
could see this word and mooning didn't
mean the same thing in Japan in Japanese
and I could see the look on people's
faces right because I'm trying to learn
how to read people's faces better and
they look confused and I was thinking to
myself how do you explain what mooning
is in jet in Japan but this isn't the
kind of thing that Japanese
schoolchildren do on their school bus
let me tell you and I realized that
there was a long way to explain what
mooning is and there was a quick short
way to explain what mooting is and I was
torn trying to figure out which way to
explain it decided to just skip it all
together actually some of my friends
started mooning cars I guess is if it
weren't for the values instilled on me
when I was little I probably would have
joined them but I didn't do it this guy
has more emotional intelligence but he
still doesn't talk about emotions that
much but at least he talks about values
and le's he talks about resisting the
pressure yeah well that's part that's
you you're actually right he says maybe
the reason they're not talking about
their feelings is because they're kids
and kids don't talk about their feelings
and and he's right when we look at how
people do on our test as they get older
and older they do better and better and
it's one of the I'm 47 years old and
it's one of the great things that makes
me happy in my life is that between age
45 and 50 that's where you get the best
scores on this test and so I'm right
you've got a ways to go yet another
whatever 30 years or so but I'm I'm
hitting my peak here here's here's the
kid who scored the highest in our in our
group okay I don't want to make this a
competition it's not a cup
it's not good or bad to score high but
people differ and everybody can learn to
be better at this thing it's like
learning how to be hit baseball better
or spell better or what have you it's a
skill so this person has very high score
and and I think this is a boy he says
once my friends wanted to sneak into
someone's room and paint him while he
slept please don't try this it's a very
bad idea it began as joking around
wouldn't it be funny could you believe
if we did this then it slowly evolved
into dares I bet you wouldn't do it I
dare you to do it I felt like it was
betraying the trust I had with this
person I didn't feel right sneaking up
on a sleeping person with no way to
defend himself and I thought doing this
would make the person have his feelings
hurt right he's worrying about the
feelings of the other guy I know how
little pranks like like this could
really hurt somebody's feelings right
this guy is worrying about the feelings
of the other person so what happens I
told them straight out that it was a
degrading thing to do that it's it was a
bad thing to do and they shouldn't be so
cruel what would my parents have said my
parents would have said they were proud
of me but maybe I also want a perfectly
harmless joke what I think has higher
emotional intelligence the parents or
they I won't make you I won't make you
but what you see here is the kid is
talking about feelings talking about the
feelings of the other person actually
showing what some of what we would call
emotional intelligence it was we
actually had a verbal intelligence it's
a it's a vocabulary test basically gives
us a little sense of we just want to
show that all of these kids are more or
less the same terms of their general
vocabulary their general verbal
intelligence so what has happened in the
last ten years or so is the idea of
emotional intelligence
has become very popular so this was a
best-selling book that was written about
ten years ago and it made people all
over the world know about emotional
intelligence which both made us proud
but also nervous because at the time
that this became so popular there wasn't
much science we had written a couple of
articles with no experiments in them no
studies in them and yet everybody was
paying attention and this is one of the
problems in doing science sometimes the
general public starts to get a sense
that the science is way ahead of where
it really is and that puts pressure on
the scientists to try to come through
and and and and and and fill out the
story and that's a difficult situation
so it got covered all over the world
this is a magazine in Germany you see at
the very top what's your EQ this is a
magazine in Spain this is a magazine in
Japan like Superman and all over the
world people have started using
emotional intelligence in interesting
ways using it to help put people in the
right kind of jobs right so let's say
you're running a trucking company and
you have to pick the people who are
going to drive the long distances by
themselves alone versus the people who
drive the short distances and make
deliveries and interact with lots of
people who do you want your most
emotionally intelligent truck driver to
be the guy who drives alone for hours
across the United States or the guy who
has to work with people probably
understanding politics there's been
interesting looks at the most recent
elections trying to figure out why
certain candidates win in certain
candidates lose by looking at the way
they connect emotionally with other
people
marketing like a television commercial
how does emotion play a role in getting
people to buy things even things they
don't need and my favorite is in schools
we're starting to see maybe in some of
your schools was dining to see people
being taught about their emotions
learning how to talk about them learning
how to share their feelings learning how
to become aware of the
feelings of others my favorite one is in
Australia the way in which Jim is now
being taught through a new curriculum a
new PE physical education curriculum is
that Jim is actually not about learning
to be a better baseball player or
learning to be a better football player
it's really about learning how to be a
graceful winner learning how not to be a
sore loser learning how to work in a
team right it's about Jim is an emotions
class right how many of you think your
gym class is an emotions class not too
many mine wasn't that's for sure and so
it's a new approach to Jim and there's a
the guy who's head of all gym teachers
in Australia is a guy named Graham Dodd
he's known to his friends as Dottie and
what daddy is trying to do is teach gym
teachers how to teach about emotions in
gym class all right let me stop there
and bring on dr. Brackett who will do a
little bit on how you can learn to have
more emotional intelligence
okay can everybody hear me right yeah
great alright so what we're gonna start
off with now is what Peter and I and
some other people I have worked on is
what we call a blueprint for emotional
intelligence this is for parents for
students for teachers and for everyone
to use you saw that the first area of
emotional intelligence was this idea of
perceiving emotions and faces right so
can you detect for example how someone
is feeling or are you are you even aware
of how you're feeling yourself right and
the way we like to use this in our daily
lives is let's say you're having an
altercation right you're having a fight
with someone or someone's about to argue
with you right take a moment and just
think for one second right how how is
this other person feeling and why is
this important well emotions can send
data right about people we learn right
if I can see that that person coming
after me is quite angry I know to get
the heck out there right all right no
maybe I better think about a strategy
right to start using to help me handle
the situation right I also teach martial
arts and this is one of the key things
that I can use right if I have an enemy
coming towards me and I can see in his
face or her face is anger right which I
know is an irrational emotion right when
someone's really angry they're not
thinking well let me not hurt this
person they're just thinking of a way to
get at you right I can say well do I
have the skills to handle this person
well if they're that big maybe but if
they're 300 pounds and and this big it's
telling me get out of there fast the
other thing we have the second area of
emotional intelligence is this idea of
using emotions right so what we can also
do let's say you're let's talk to the
parents now for a moment so you've
noticed that your child is angry or
upset right the second thing you can ask
yourself is how do I want myself to feel
and how do I want them to feel right
what kind of mood do
want to induced in that child or even in
myself too in order to handle the
situation better yeah oh you're right
good point there you go
so how do I want to feel how do I want
you to feel this is the second hour of
emotional intelligence right you can use
this for example as dr. salivate talked
about it whoops
a little while ago let's see if I can
get this thing at work I'll skip that
part in right if you're feeling in a
very if you're feeling negative right
you're really down right that might not
be the best time to ask your parent for
your allowance right right you know the
best kind of awesome for your allowance
is when they're feeling very positive
and up right the same thing goes in
school right as a professor myself you
know if I'm in a negative mood right
it's probably not a good time to come to
my office and ask me you know to change
your grade right but if you come in and
say well you know that class is really
great today I loved your lecture by the
way you know I'm just curious is there
any way you can you know give me a
better grade you know I may not do it
but I'm certainly gonna be more likely
to the third area of emotional
intelligence that we try to have you
think about is this idea of
understanding emotions right do you have
the vocabulary for example to express
yourself clearly right what we know for
example is that young children kids in
4th 5th 6th grades you don't have the
vocabulary to express themselves what
are they likely to do right if you can't
tell someone how you're feeling how does
it make you feel someone just
volunteered frustrated right and what is
a what is frustration leads you to do I
get angry right and then you get angry
and what do you do right I'm sorry you
can act out exactly right if you can't
tell someone listen I'm really feeling
upset about what the way you've treated
me the other day right you get this
emotion inside it just stirs up right
you don't know how to express it
and you go back to primitive that
earlier brain part of your brain that's
survival and you just go in there and
beat the heck out of them ok and what we
find is that young kids and children who
have a good vocabulary to describe their
feelings actually are perceived as dr.
salary by their teachers as dr. Sullivan
said by their teachers to be more
pro-social to get along better with
children even by their peers
class right so we've done research for
example where we have a whole class fill
out a survey about who's more popular
who gets along well with others and what
we find is that children who have better
emotions or capillaries are better are
perceived to be liked more and by their
peers and their teachers now this fourth
layer of emotional intelligence as we
talked about is that you have managing
emotions right so let's take this let's
go through the whole procedure now let's
say you're gonna really use this
blueprint for your everyday life right
so the first thing that happens if you
say to yourself all right how am I
feeling right how would the other person
feeling do I know what's going on inside
me do I know what's going inside the
other person right we're not always good
at this so what's a good thing to do ask
right don't just assume right I've had
this happen as a as a teacher I had one
student who used to watch you stir cuz
she's a graduate student come into my
into the lab and I'd be grading her
papers and I created but just reading
over her work and she said I had to
leave the room right which was kind of
weird to me and I was like well why he
had to leave the room she's like because
you look disgusted when you're reading
my paper
I'm not disgusted I'm actually really
interested in it she's like no you're
just
I just cannot be in the room with you
when you're reading my paper right now
what happened is that we actually have a
great relationship now why because she
told me that right I really wasn't
feeling disgusted by her work but I
guess I was so intense by reading it and
like using a red pen or something that
it made her very nervous so she just
said to me well you know it looks like
you're really discussed it and I said
well I'm glad you told me that because
the truth is I think your work is
amazing and I'm just interested in it
and I'm just really intense but if she
had never asked me what would have had
what could have happened she would leave
there feeling nervous and sad right
because she's thinking that I don't like
her work well actually I really do so
this is the idea of using these skills
in your everyday life right if you're
not sure just ask somebody using
emotions right how do I want to feel how
do you want to feel right if I want you
to feel good maybe I'll give you a
compliment or maybe exactly just like
that do I have the vocabulary to express
myself again can I do I have the
language to actually articulate clearly
how I'm feeling and finally what am I
willing to do
and what am i able to do right do I know
the strategies a lot of us just don't
know it right we weren't taught right we
weren't taught that maybe if I got a
let's take out my cell phone ring right
now and something really bad happened
like a family member got very sick right
it might be the best thing for me just
for a few minutes to distract myself
right let's just okay I'm gonna deal
with that but let me just get through
this next ten minutes right if I started
hysterical crying and really getting
upset maybe it wouldn't be the best
thing to do I could handle it for a few
seconds and then and then deal with my
emotions later on appropriately now what
I want to do is show you a program that
I've worked on for the last few years
and it's in many metals middle schools
right now and we're testing it is just
think about this for a moment
have you recently felt isolated or as if
you didn't belong somewhere how many
people have felt that way raise your
hand really high really really high how
many of you felt that way the last month
or so okay now put your hand up for a
moment how many of you are willing to
share that experience okay so this is
interesting right
everybody's felt this feeling before I
certainly would not you know one of the
reasons why I became a martial artist
because I was tiny and everybody was
picking on me and that my best dream was
when I had a karate school ten years ago
one of those kids came into the karate
school you know and I was already a
black belt so it was very interesting
experience I felt that way right so I
could tell you a story right when I was
young and I was picked on you know that
was the motivating factor and I began to
got a black thought in karate right but
I'm this is my field you know I feel
comfortable doing this right but a lot
of you here if Billy feels weird to talk
about a time when you were isolated and
lonely and why do you think that is yeah
yeah
right now just stand up for a moment do
you mind
I'm gonna isolate you an alien a chair
now just raise your hand again how many
of you have felt in the last month or
two really had it an experience where
you just felt like a little
uncomfortable isolated separate raise
your hand okay turn around
just turn around right look at everybody
right a lot of people have felt that way
right but for some reason we don't want
to share it and that's the interesting
question what's that okay great
please do do you mind your school's
basketball team
uh-huh
Wow all right good so I mean I can
imagine that how you feel right you're
on this team you don't get any points
and if you're one of the shortest kid on
the team okay well now that this what is
your name what's your name I need again
about two wagons alright we're gonna
stop you there because okay so now what
is your name
Harrison now that Harrison share
something can anyone anyone else do it
for us I know any other you might sure
wanna yeah of course uh-huh wow that
must have been hard for you right I
understand that
great so it's how did it feel to tell
talk about that it's a little difficult
right and I understand that one of the
rules we have in our classroom when we
do this is that there's a rule right
that there's no ridiculing students
right this is the opportunity for
everyone to become comfortable sharing
their feelings and that anyone who
doesn't do it properly not who doesn't
share properly but abuses this privilege
gets in a little bit of trouble now what
I want to do is introduce you to a new
word right and some of you in this room
may know it and some of you don't but
this feeling of being separate or
isolated right can be cap can be
captured in a fancy award and that word
is alienation right and the warrant
alienation means to feel or be isolated
from someone or some people now the idea
here right this is thinking about how
our brains work is the way I introduce
this word to you right now how many of
you be honest
don't worry about if you want to share
it or not right now
but when I said how many of you felt
isolated before really went inside your
heads and sort of thinking back back
back about a time when you felt
alienated or separate raise your hand
most of you did right it's like don't
think of a white bear right what happens
right I'm not gonna say anything I'm
sorry thank you so the point is is that
all of you your brain started getting
activated in thinking about a time in
your lives when you felt isolated right
and that's the idea but we want to do is
when we're introducing new language or
new words as we want to get you involved
in the process and by making a personal
connection we're opening up your brain
to new information all right second part
of the program let's look at this right
now now that you know the word
alienation right what it means and who
can tell me what it means somebody new
rage right son no no no no somebody new
I want somebody yes what does it mean it
means to be isolated from something or
somebody yeah now that we know the word
what the word alienation means how does
this design look like the word
alienation can someone tell me yeah you
they're separated right so give me a
sentence and that describes that that
design
right the circle is lonely from the
triangle right or what's the word that
we're using right now alienated right so
the circle is alienated from the
triangle by the line
anyone else can tell a different story
looking at that design yeah that's
interesting that's a good one
the circle a triangle are separate or
alienate from another because they're
different or don't have the same
feelings great okay now why do we do
this well what we think is it's a very
interesting way to get everyone
interested in the idea of feelings right
firstly right designs provide what we
call a nonverbal interpretation right
you've already felt that feeling right
by me asking you that question the
second thing that we've done here is
we've gotten to visualize that feeling
of alienation right you can see for
example the alienation is that idea of
being separate and we have many designs
for example this one on the left let me
try the word commitment can anyone tell
me how that word how that design looks
like the word commitment one mother is
thinking like my son or daughter if she
goes through this program I'm out of
here
alright how about that what do you think
yes yep excellent right the one line on
the right is committed to going in a
certain direction where the other ones
are not sure what they're doing I think
that's great I know one else have a
different explanation for that
yes to you ok that's great so how does
it look like that
okay that could be that way also right
there's no the key thing about this is
that there's no right or wrong answer
right as long as you can justify your
explanation and you did a great job it
doesn't look like the word commitment to
you because of that we're for that child
over there it did now I can give you
some other examples this one how about
greed how does that look like the word
greed anyone want to try that yes you
over here okay
so then it looks like the word greed
because the circles are keeping all the
dots how about someone else another
person give me an example for why that
looks like greed in the back right so
the the circle on the right is greedy
right because it's taking all the dots
away good how about this one let's use
the word elated hey later is a fancy
word for feeling happy so how does that
design look like the word happy yeah
they're all joined together great anyone
else someone else have a different
example yeah looks like a string of
pearls expensive ones of that matter
right now I'll give you a funny example
when I was teaching this program just a
few weeks ago in a class with ten year
old boys and girls one young girl said
to me you know to me that looks like the
word elated because the circles
represent areas of Iraq and the lines
represent troops going in to freeing all
the people who are captured and that's
why it looks happy to me right now that
was very moving for me it was an amazing
experience another example no offense of
the parents in this room was about a
month ago I was in Vancouver giving a
talk to parents and one woman said it
looks like happy cuz it's getting bigger
and I was like okay you know right and
then I made this comment I said well I
know this eleven-year-old ten-year-old
girl you know give this example and
everybody in the room was like shocked
right my students here you know I did
this example when I was teaching my
class and emotion intelligence and they
got insulted that I said I was telling
eleven year olds were more creative than
they were because they were saying
things well it looks like elated because
you know they were giving very simple
right reasons and I said to them one of
the reasons why this is so fun for
children is that because it's what we
call divergent thinking it's thinking
outside the box right what happens a lot
of times in school is that we're taught
to have one correct answer for our
reading right we read something and you
get one answer that's correct well with
this kind of program and this kind of
activity it's not that way right there's
many correct answers as long as you can
justify them now let's just think about
this in the real world right we all know
right that the word alienated now means
to feel separate or not part of
something what I would like someone to
do for me if someone knew please it's to
tell me something that's happening in
our society right now and what's this
experience has been happening yeah
okay so give me can you give me like
something that happened the news
recently or even something you learned
in history or science how does this how
does this remind you of something in the
real world in which that experience
happen slavery so what would the circle
represent so the circle would represent
this is what we're talking about 60
years ago in the south and the circle
represents white people yes right so
he's saying this reminds me of
segregation that the the circle
represents one kind of person white
people this triangle represents another
type back then for black people and the
line is a separation factor great and it
would also have another idea
yeah religion so how how does that look
like religion to you okay so hey this is
right so now he's relating this to
religion he's saying that we have
different belief systems right one
religion another religion they don't
they're not compatible right so they're
alienated from one another that's a
great example how about one more yeah oh
that's a very relevant one right yes
okay so what we're getting at here is
this idea of real-world associations for
the word alienation now what I'd like to
talk about with you what's your name
Peter Peter what do you think we can do
oh well I'm a little upset right we have
these we have one religion we have
another religion and they seem alien
ated from one another right because of
their different beliefs so what could we
do to reduce this alienation
okay
so you're saying that these differences
are not that important not as important
as we think they are I think that's
pretty interesting
I agree with you anyone else have
another idea on top of Peters idea of
how we can make things how we can make
different religious let's a lien a tit
from one another
Unitarian okay well what can you explain
that for me for a moment okay all right
good that's yeah how about you
say it again Protestants all right let's
take another example right someone here
circ talked about segregation in the
past right that that certain people feel
alienated from other people right let's
does a class right don't work classroom
here what what can we do to help but
let's say we're talking about little
children who feel alienated from one
another right because they're just
different how do we make them feel less
alienated yeah right so we can focus on
what they have in common that's a great
idea do you have another idea
communication right so show that maybe
like with religion there's not so many
differences which we really have the
same we're the same people we're just a
little different yeah how about you
right
so sharing more maybe right sharing more
of my life experiences etc and then we
get along a little better anyone else
have an idea yeah play a game okay how
about you
right very nice so she's saying by
sharing more right we realized that
there's nuts there's not so much
differences and one isn't really
superior to the other now we can go on
and on and on and one of the problems
actually with this program is that
teachers are complaining that the
children in the classes don't want to
stop talking which is a great thing for
me because I like that idea they don't
like it because they need to actually
move on to other subject matters but the
point here right that I'm trying to make
is that by taking this we're just we
just started with one word the word
alienation right and now we've gotten to
a whole broad thing about group
differences right so what I think is
that this word becomes a world in a
sense that we learn for example in the
past I've done this in classes where
we've talked about physical disabilities
with children who feel alienated like
because they can't participate in gym so
I brought up questions in the class and
said well what can we do to make
children with disabilities feel more
comfortable right and then students
would say things like well we could you
know change an activity in order to make
them feel better right that they can
participate in and then I'd say well
that's a great idea
can someone else tell me something and
then once it it would say well you know
if we change it in front of that person
that could make them even feel worse
right because they know we're doing it
differently but because we know in class
you know who's there right we should do
things in advance and by preparing in
advance then we could just do the
activity without making it so obvious
and what I'm getting at here is that by
having these kinds of discussions right
people build off one another and people
get a much greater understanding of this
word and how this concept can help
people this is just one word and our
program they go through a whole bunch of
words all right why is this important
well I think all of you said this ready
a few things right we learned how others
think and feel and act we become smarter
about the world around us right we
become comfortable talking about social
interaction right we're using current
events like the woman talked about here
the issue that's going on in Florida we
use history we use religion we use
children with disabilities as different
examples and we've learned what's going
on the real world one thing that
happened to me recently when I was
talking to parents is that one parent
said that she came home from work and
her child was looking through the
newspaper you know crazily trying to
find how
word adapt related to the real world and
she was you know like just blown away by
that right my job now I was looking in
the newspaper to try to find real-world
applications of emotion words right and
and that child shared with me her
example which was that this is the back
of a month few months ago which was that
Christopher Reeves wife must has to
learn to adapt to a new life right
because her husband has gone now and
she's gonna have to change you know the
way she lives every day I thought that
was pretty great to hear from a ten year
old student now let's just finish up
here by bringing it over to you again
and what dr. soundwave and I are
interested in is so do you think these
skills really matter what do you think
why why do you think these skills matter
now don't just you know because we're
here talking to you about it you know
agree right it's a little bit of a
forced you know we're forcing you to
agree with us but don't feel that way
honestly why do you think these skills
matter what do you how do you think why
do you think the perception of emotion
in a face is gonna help you live a
better life yeah yeah
great helps you relate to one another
right if I can feel like if I'm giving a
talk and I say that makes you
uncomfortable right and I can perceive
that right that maybe if I have a good
skills I might be able to talk to you
about it and say did I say something to
hurt you
yeah that might make us have a better
friendship anybody else Yeah right
yeah so you can understand people more
that just didn't of itself is great oh
yeah please go ahead
yes great yeah yes
right right of course of course yes
you're right now let's just go on to the
next few questions here so we already
talked about this one we'll skip this
one we talked about what happens when
you can't express yourself and your
feelings but what do you think about
teaching these and what do you think do
you think your class would be better if
you had that students all of our ten to
twelve to fifteen to eighteen year olds
what would happen in your classroom if
this was going on yeah
uh-huh
good I agree with you that's why I'm
here today yes you don't okay let's go
why
oh so you're talking about testing now
right good I agree with you I agree with
you about testing right but let's not
talk about getting a score on a test
let's say do you think that for example
having students in your class get better
at reading faces right what do you think
about that idea or getting really having
a conversation about at the beginning of
the day right
so how could we get them to be better at
it
that's a good idea also right and we do
do that individually right when some
children have problems right they go see
a psychologist and they help them get
skills right and you have a good point
there and we could talk about that
anybody else have another idea about yes
or no why should the even one okay great
so there well how how did I do that
oh great uh-huh that's great
Wow so it sounds like you have a pretty
cool school or at least progressive how
do you think this is related to academic
success why do you think that children
who are good at these skills actually do
better in school I actually did a study
recently in another country in Spain and
what we found was that high school
students who had higher emotional
intelligence did better at the end of
the school year right that was after
taking all their general intelligence
into consideration why do you think
these skills matter for giving and
getting a good grade on a test yeah
okay can you explain a little bit more
okay so you have more confidence maybe
right and your ability to perform anyone
else have an idea of why these skills
might matter for your test-taking
ability how many of you get nervous when
you take a test
I get nervous right when I had to take
standardized tests like those tests in
school right and made me all nervous
that I was gonna do well alright so
maybe if I had skills right if I could
talk to the teacher and say I'm really
nervous about taking this test right she
or the heat would then maybe help calm
me down and say well let's take a deep
breaths right we develop strategies and
skills to help us do better good alright
I want to finish up because I didn't
realize how late it is but how why do
you think this would matter for your
friendships why do you think this would
why do you think people who have high
emotional intelligence get along better
with other people somebody who hasn't
yes Yeah right maybe they use that
blueprint right so my friend is annoyed
with me right if I'm not good at these
skills I don't recognize it which is a
big problem right because now they're
irritated with me cuz I don't recognize
that they're eret ated right and I don't
have the vocabulary to express myself to
them right and I don't have the ability
to handle it right we've found people in
businesses for example that are very
good at some of these skills right they
can read everybody's face right which is
a great skill but they're really bad at
managing okay so what happens they see
everybody hates them or disgusted but
they don't wanna handle tonight is
crumble right they're like they're in a
talk right now and I see everybody's
discussing look right but I have no
ability to root to regulate it all right
so I think we're finished thank you very
much for your time and dr. Sullivan I
appreciate your attention
you